and then i had been working on this
george carlin documentary i started it
right before the pandemic
awesome i let me tell you i i didn't
really i hate i'm embarrassed to say but
i really it's not that i wasn't a big
george carlin fan i just wasn't educated
on him and this boy is this an education
of george carlin the influence he had
who he was the hardships he went through
when he hit rock bottom and like other
comedians were sort of making fun of him
at a certain time you know when he was
doing blow and his wife was an alcoholic
and his daughter stuck in the middle all
this [ __ ] i was like
this is intense as hell and i really
learned a lot i love this documentary
when does it come out uh it's going to
come out mid to late may
and i'm really proud of it in the
beginning i thought i don't know how we
could do something as good as the gary
shandling documentary because gary was
so open about his feelings he really
expressed himself right in every
situation he just he was just cut in a
vein everywhere that's what he was
looking for he was looking for the
answers right yeah and he wanted to tell
you what he was feeling and he wanted to
go deep and he wanted to talk about
going deep so when you would look up
interviews that he did with people like
kevin smith or mark maron
it was all there i mean there was a
great line gary had in one of the
interviews i think it was with mark
maron
it might have been kevin smith he said
life is short
but not short enough
and so there was all this stuff and i
thought well george carlin never told us
anything about himself was it just the
period was the sense of like just the
time period that he sort of grew up in
probably i mean it was an era where we
didn't know that much about alan king's
life right and people from that era and
his act none of it was personal
zero he didn't tell you about his wife
and his daughter and
he
he it was all in his mind and his
observations of people and life but it
wasn't an observation of his behavior
right and then when he did interviews he
he rarely went deep about any of it but
then we found that he was working on his
autobiography
with tony hendra
uh who played the manager in spinal tap
who was a
writer and he passed away i believe this
year
and
he
talked to tony for this book
for 23 hours and we found these tapes
and you listen so when you make a
documentary how much harder is it to
make a documentary than actually making
a film because you have a script you
follow the script you you know
but with a documentary it's sort of like
the research that goes into it to find
all these things and then piece them
together and make it somewhat linear
how long do you have a team of people
helping you out with this
oh yeah i mean it's it's a lot of work
to
to just listen to his 14 hbo specials
you listen to every special i mean
i can't say i listen to every second of
every special i i usually use my team to
go let's prioritize
there's a lot of stuff that isn't as
good as the best stuff right and so we
don't have to
you know get
super deep on the things that weren't
working but it becomes clear that
there's 14 hours of stuff
maybe there's four incredible hours that
we have to really pay attention to